what we're going to do in this video is
think a little bit about place value
tables and sometimes they're referred to
as place value charts in previous videos
we've already talked about the idea of
place value and a place value table or a
place value chart it's just a way to say
how much we have how much value we have
in each place in a very very clear way
so here they say use the place value
chart to write sixty thousand two
hundred and twenty nine and this is the
place value table or place value chart
right over here they say plate
enter a digit one digit number in each
box of the place value chart so really
all they're saying is how many ten
thousands do we have how many thousands
how many hundreds how many tens and how
many ones and like always it's always a
good idea to try to have a go at it
before I do it with you so why don't you
do that why don't you pause the video
and on a little piece of scratch paper
say how many ten thousands are in sixty
thousand two hundred twenty-nine how
many thousands are there how many
hundreds how many tens and how many ones
alright now let's do this together so we
could start at the left in the ten
thousands place this is the ones place
this is the tens place and we did a
little bit neater so this is ones tens
hundreds thousands ten thousands so we
can see that we have six ten thousands
so all we would do is say we'd put a six
there we have six ten thousands and then
how many thousands oh that would be one
place over to the right this is
interesting we can see very clearly we
actually have zero thousands so zero
thousands you might say hey when you say
this out you say sixty thousand two
hundred twenty-nine now we have 60
thousands well you already accounted for
that in the six ten thousands six ten
thousands is 60,000
but just in the in the thousands place
you have none and then we move on to the
hundreds place you can see very clearly
we have two hundredths and then we can
go to the tens place and I'm written
over a little bit but we have two tens
and then last but not least we have nine
ones and we're done and so the whole
point of this video is to just get you
comfortable with this type of format
with a place value table
or place value chart and all it is is a
way of really clearly writing out how
much value you have in each place in a
number like this